LIKE TO GET STARTED I THINK IT'S
NINE O'CLOCK.
WITH THIS MORNING'S ELECTIONS
AND REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE
HEARING -- BEFORE WE BEGIN.
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENS
TO MAKE IT FIRST WOULD EVERYONE
PLEASE ANSWER CELLPHONES.
SECOND I HAVE A LETTER FROM THE
SPEAKER APPOINTING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE. TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON FOR THE
PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
AND WE HAVE AN UPDATE TO THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING ITEM NUMBER THREE A
BEFORE SIXTY BY SOMETHING NUMBER
KILEY.
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WE'RE
GONNA GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
AND I SEE MR CHORE HERE -- SO
WHY DON'T WE GET STARTED MR
GEORGIA READY TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
GOOD MORNING.
THE MONEY CHAIR BERMAN AND ONE
COMMITTEE MEMBER STAFF MEMBERS --
HERE TODAY -- TO PRESENT THE A.
B.. TWO SIX FIVE A TO PROVIDE
THE VOTERS.
WITH THE BASIC INFORMATION FOR
JUSTICE ELECTIONS [inaudible]
I HOPE.
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO WILL UNDERSTAND THE
THE POINT OF DESIRE A. B. TWO
SIX THREE D. -- BY BREEDING.
IT MIGHT BE -- SUGGESTION UNDER
THIS -- CURRENT -- ELECTION LAW
THE SECRETARY OF THE STATE THE
PROVIDE SELF VOTER INFORMATION
CRIES. FOR ALL STATE LEVEL
ELECTIONS.
BOTH ELECTRONICALLY AND IN PRINT.
AND THE WHY THE CURRENT
INFORMATION PROVIDED A BY THE
SECRETARY OF THE STATE SARAH
OFFICER DOES GAVE A MORE ROSA.
BASIC INFORMATION ON THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES AND THE APPELLATE
COURT JUSTICES.
WE FIND THAT THAT THIS ACT IS ON
NOT THE CODIFIED.
AND THE ALL OF THE COURTS.
ARE AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
COUNTIES.
IN THE WHAT.
IF AT ALL ANY INFORMATION IS A
PROVIDED. FOR THE SUPERIOR COURT
JUSTICE IS.
WE HAVE ALL ALL GOING THROUGH A
OF BALLOTS AND THE SEA IN THE
SELECTION OF OCT.
JUSTICES FIELD WITH THE YES IS
AN UNKNOWN WAS.
A NAME SOMETIMES A AND THE A
SEAT NUMBER.
IN EXAMINING NOT THIS PAST
ELECTION WITH THE A RECORD.
THE RECORD HIGH TORN OUT THE IT
IS INTERESTING TO SEE THAT THE
WITH THE TWELVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION BALLOTS SO TURNED IN.
A DURING THE ARE NON
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
OVER THREE POINT FIVE MILLION OF
THOSE ABOUT LOS A LEFTY JUSTICES
SUCH ELECTION BLACK.
IF YOU TALK TO CALIFORNIA'S SO
ACROSS THIS STATE.
OR EVEN TO A JUSTICE OF
ASSOCIATIONS.
THE REPORT IS SOUGHT ECHO -- TO
SO MANY PEOPLE.
CALL AND ASK FOR INFORMATION.
ON WHO THESE JUST AREN'T
JUSTICES ARE AND THE WIDE THE
BALLOT THOUGHT LOOKS DIFFERENT
FOR THEM.
AB.
TWO SIX FIVE LOOKS AT THE IS
SECRETARY OF A STATE SO. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OF VOTER GUIDE
THE FOR THE SUPREME COURT.
AS THE EXAMPLE FOR OBJECTIVE
INFORMATION FOR VOTERS -- TO
HAVE.
IN SEEKING TO CAST THE FOR FULL
JUSTICE.
AB TWO SIX FIVE US SIMPLY
CODIFIES THE CURRENT PRACTICE OF
THE SECRETARY STATE. FOR THE
ESTATE LEVEL REPORTS.
AND THE REQUIRES SOME COUNTIES.
TO DO THE SAME IN PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION FOLLOWING
INFORMATION GAINED THE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA.
COURTS AND IS A FREE TO REQUEST
[inaudible]
NAME [inaudible]
CURRENT TITLE.
DATA BAR ASSOCIATION EDUCATIONAL
BACKGROUND.
FASHION ON LEVEL BACKGROUND.
JUDICIARY BACKGROUND.
IN ACKNOWLEDGING THE COSTS.
OF THAT COULD BE -- IN CURVED UP
BY ADDING THESE UP BASIC
INFORMATION FOR EACH JUSTICE
SELF ON THE BALLOT.
A. B. TOOL SIX FIVE FOUR ONLY
REQUIRES THAT THIS INFORMATION
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR THE RULE
DIGITAL MEANS.
AND A PRINTER AT THE DISCRETION
OF THE ELECTION OFFICIALS.
AB TWO SIX FIVE VOTE WERE SIMPLY
TAKE A SMALLER STEP. TO CORRECT
ON ON ON A DRASTIC ISSUE THAT IS
TOP PERPETUATING YEAR TO YEAR IN
VOTER INFORMATION ON
CALIFORNIA'S SUCH JUSTICES.
AND THE STRENGTH IN OUR VOTERS
WITH THE OBJECTIVE INFORMATION
WHEN THE CAST THAT THE BALLOTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI FOR THE
VERY THOROUGH PRESENTATION -- ON
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BREAK TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE
GALLAGHER.
MARK STONE MARK STONE HERE LOW
[inaudible]
MAYES.
IS HERE MULLIN.
MULLIN HERE WEBER.
WEBER HERE HAVE A QUORUM RATES --
WITH THAT -- DOCTOR CHOICE THE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BUT NO I DON'T HAVE ABOUT THE WE
ARE IN CONTACT WITH VIA A COLIN --
THE BORDER OF THE JUDICIARY
BRANCH GREAT AND THEN ALSO
CALIFORNIA'S JUSTICE ASSOCIATION
AND THAT THEY ARE ALL -- IN A
SPEAKING OFF IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO CALLS FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
I HAVE A MOTION.
I HAVE A SECOND.
DOOR TO DOOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THIS INFORMATION NOT -- THIS
IDEA CAME UP THROUGH MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES SO MANY
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT CALLED TO
WHOM DO I LOOK.
FOR ACTUALLY I I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
KNOWLEDGE OF THEM YES OR NO.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS TOP UP
FUNDAMENTAL BASIC INFORMATION
BORDERS ARE SEEKING FULL AND I
ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION TO VOTERS ABOUT
JUDICIAL ELECTIONS.
IN ABOUT THE JUSTICES IN
CANDIDATES FOR JUDGE THAT THEY
ARE ASKED TO VOTE ON WHAT IS
OFTEN HAVE VERY LITTLE
INFORMATION ABOUT JUDICIAL
CANDIDATES SO PROVIDING
STANDARDIZED INFORMATION ABOUT
EACH CANDIDATE MAY HELP EDUCATE
VOTERS. FOR THAT REASON I'M
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE
GALLAGHER.
MARK STONE.
MARK STONE NO LOW.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THAT BILLS OUT ON A FOUR
TO ONE VOTE WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND RESOLUTIONS
THANK YOU MOVING NEXT TO ITEM
NUMBER TEN ON THE AGENDA AB TEN
THIRTY SIX BY SOMEONE OVER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WITH THESE AMENDMENTS
A. B. TEN THIRTY SIX WILL
INCREASE VOTER REGISTRATION
VOTING IN TWO WAYS.
FIRST IT WOULD REQUIRE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO UPDATE
REGULATIONS DIRECTING COUNTY
OFFICIALS TO DEVELOP.
VOTER OUTREACH PROGRAMS I THINK
THOSE LOCAL OFFICIALS LIKE JESSE
SALINAS HERE FROM YELLOW COUNTY
WHO WORKS INCREDIBLY HARD TO GET
EVERYONE TO PURCHASE WHICH HAS
BEEN OUR DEMOCRACY.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY COUNTIES HAVE
VERY LOW REGISTRATION RATES IN
SOME COUNTIES CLOSE 240% OF
ELIGIBLE VOTERS ARE NOT
REGISTERED.
THIS BILL PROVIDES TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF
LOCAL OUTREACH PROGRAMS WHICH A
RESORT RESULT IN GREATER VOTER
REGISTRATION AND PARTICIPATION.
SECOND AB TEN THIRTY SIX CREATES
A HIGH SCHOOL VOTER EDUCATION
PILOT PROGRAM IN YELLOW COUNTY.
THIS PILOT WILL STUDY MOCK
ELECTIONS OF HIGH SCHOOLS
CONDUCTED WITH OFFICIALS
ELECTIONS EQUIPMENT LIKE VOTING
MACHINES IN BALLOTS.
THIS TYPE OF MARK ALEXIAN IS
AFFECTED FOR TEACHING YOUNGER
GENERATIONS HOW TO CAST A BALLOT
SO THEY ARE EXCITED INCOMPETENT
WHEN THEY GO TO THE FIRST POLL.
CREATING THIS PILOT WILL
LEGITIMIZE THE EFFORTS IN YOLO
COUNTY AND SURE THE RESULTS OF
THIS PROGRAM CAN INFORM IMPROVE
MOCK ELECTION STATEWIDE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
JESSE SALINAS REAL COUNTY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR BERMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JESSE SALINAS
I'M DEAL A COUNTY ASSESSOR CLERK
RECORDER AND REGISTER VOTERS.
ON TODAY AND BEFORE YOU AS THE
REGISTER VOTERS IN YOLO COUNTY
AND THE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS MOCK ELECTION HAPPENED IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THAT WE
SHARED THE OPPORTUNITY WITH THE
VERY SUPERINTENDENTS AND A SMALL
SCHOOL DID THAT OUT IN THIS PART
OF WHAT WE EXPERIENCE THERE WAS
THAT OUR OVERALL.
THERE WERE A 59% OF THE STUDENTS
PARTICIPATED WHICH ACCORDING TO
THE ADMINISTRATORS AT WHICH IS A
REALLY HIGH NUMBER FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE LOCAL
ELECTIONS.
THEY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
A BALLOT THAT WAS AN OFFICIAL
LOOKING BALLOT NOW I WILL SAY
THAT WE DID TWEAK IT A LITTLE
BIT WE ALLOWED THEM TO PUT A TAG
LINE IN THERE BECAUSE WE NEEDED
TO MAKE IT A LITTLE SPECIAL FOR
THESE YOUNG FOLKS SO THEY HAD.
FUN WITH IT.
UP AND THE BEAUTY OF IT IS WHEN
YOU START TO SEE THE DATA WE
BROKE IT DOWN BY CLASS THE
FRESHMAN CLASS PARTICIPATED AT
50%.
THE SOPHOMORE CLASS PARTICIPATED
AT 59% AND WHEN YOU SAW THE
JUNIORS THEY PARTICIPATED THAT
70%.
THAT'S A GREAT.
GREAT DATA TO BE ABLE TO START
SHOWING THAT YOUNG PEOPLE NOT
ONLY IF THEY GET THAT EXPERIENCE
GET EXCITED ABOUT IT.
THEY CAN WALK INTO AN ELECTION
IN THE FUTURE AND THEY CAN
ACTUALLY.
HELP PROMOTED WITHIN THEIR
FAMILIES TOO BECAUSE A LOT OF
THESE FOLKS THOUGHT OF THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE MYSELF INCLUDED.
TRANSLATED FOR MY PARENTS AND MY
MOM PARTICULAR AND TO BE ABLE TO
BE HAVE THEM BECOME AMBASSADORS
NOT ONLY FOR THEIR THEIR FELLOW
STUDENTS THAT DIDN'T PARTICIPATE
AND HOW EASY AND FUN IT WAS.
BUT TO ACTUALLY GET THAT
EXPERIENCE AND SHARE IT WITH
THEIR FAMILY I CAN BE A REAL I
THINK.
MAJOR TRANSFORMATIONAL POINT FOR
US HERE IN AND YOLO COUNTY
BEYOND ONCE WE GET THIS PILOT
MOVING.
AWESOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
COMPANY DID COME ON UP TO THE
MIKE AROUND THERE YOU GO AND I
THINK WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE IT SET UP.
PERFECT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
COUNCILMEMBER LAUREN FROM THE
CITY OF WINTERS SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ON BRING BACK A
COLLEAGUES BEFORE I DO THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR -- FOR FOR
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD --
AND SOME AMENDMENTS TO THE
FINDINGS AND DECORATIONS WHICH
ARE JUST DISTRIBUTED TO
EVERYBODY -- AT THE AT THE DAIS
AND WITH THAT COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR MOTIONS
OR SECONDS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS -- MS AGUIAR-CURRY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HI -- S.
HERE I VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF ON WOMEN'S
TO THIS BILL.
UPDATING THE REGULATIONS AND
REQUIRING VOTER EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH PLANTS TO BE UPDATED
PERIODICALLY WILL HELP INSURE
ALL COUNTY VOTER EDUCATION AND
NOT REACH PLANS.
ARE REFLECTIVE OF OUR CURRENT
VOTER REGISTRATION POLICIES AND
THAT RESOURCES ARE ADJUSTED
ACCORDINGLY WITH THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS AND THE
EACH WEEK TO THE FINDINGS
INTEGRATIONS I'M RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO MARK STONE.
WHAT STONE I LOW [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER I THAT BILL AS IT'S OUT ON
THE FORTY ONE VOTE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE ABSENT -- FOR WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH ME
THANK YOU PLEASURE -- AND WITH
THAT I SEE SOME A MEMBER
GONZALEZ IN THE CROWD.
IF YOU LIKE TO PRESENT AT A
NUMBER TO AB.
THREE SIXTY THREE THE MORNING
GOOD MORNING IN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SAID LIKE.
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY THREE
WOULD PROVIDE ALL VOTERS WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE EARLY
INCONVENIENTLY AT LOCATION IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
ELECTION DAY THE UNITED STATES
WAS ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED ON A
TUESDAY IN ORDER TO RELATIVELY --
TO BE RELATIVELY CONVENIENT FOR
FARMERS TO TRAVEL DAY AFTER THE
SABBATH TO APPOINT PLACE IN
RETURN IN TIME TO MARKET TO OPEN
ON WEDNESDAY.
TODAY'S WORK WEEK HOWEVER IS
FAST PACED AND LESS PREDICTABLE
WHICH IN TURN CREATES AN
OBSTACLE FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE
DURING A THIRTEEN HOUR PERIOD IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE WEEK.
A PEW RESEARCH CENTER STUDY OF
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION
FOUND THAT WHEN THE TOP REASON
CITED BY NON VOTERS WAS THAT
THEY WERE TOO BUSY OR HAD A
CONFLICTING SCHEDULE.
PEOPLE ARE OFTEN UNABLE TO CAST
A BALLOT ON TUESDAY BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T GET TIME OFF WORK OR DON'T
HAVE CHILDCARE. FOR CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES OPTING TO CONDUCT
ELECTIONS UNDER THE VOTERS
CHOICE ACT VOTERS ARE ALREADY
GIVEN THE OPTION TO VOTE EARLY
AT A VOTE CENTER IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER ONLY FIVE COUNTIES I
THINK THAT'S GROWING OUT OF
FOURTEEN ELIGIBLE COUNTIES
CONDUCTED ELECTIONS WITHIN THIS
MODEL IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SEVERAL
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES NOT
CONDUCTING VOTERS CHOICE ACT
ELECTIONS ALSO ALREADY OFFER
SOME LEVEL WE CAN VOTING EARLY
VOTING BUT THESE OPTIONS FOR
EARLY VOTINGMY ONLY BE BASIC
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS OFFICE.
WHICH CAN BE DEFAULT CALL TO
ACCESS OR MAY HAVE CONSTRAINING
HOURS OF OPERATION FOR EXAMPLE
IN MY COMMUNITY THERE IS WEEKEND
VOTING AT THE REGISTER VOTERS
BUT IF YOU I DON'T HAVE A CAR IT
WOULD TAKE YOU OVER AN HOUR TO
GET FROM.
MY COMMUNITY TO THE RED STAR.
VOTING IS THE CENTRAL COMPONENT
DEMOCRACY AND IT'S CLOSE TO FULL
PARTICIPATION AS POSSIBLE THE
CANDIDATES ELECTED IN DECISIONS
BEING MADE ARE NEVER GOING TO
TRULY REFLECT THE NEEDS ONCE AND
BACKGROUNDS OF REGULAR
CALIFORNIANS.
THERE'S STILL A LONG WAY TO GO.
AB THREE SIXTY THREE WHAT EXPAND
ACCESS TO THE BALLOT BOX FOR
CALIFORNIANS BY PROVIDING VOTERS
AN OPTION TO VOTE IN PERSON AT A
LOCATION WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY
DURING THE SATURDAY SUNDAY OR
MONDAY LEADING UP TO THE
ELECTION.
AB THREE SIXTY THREE WOULD
REQUIRE COUNTIES TO RIDE
LOCATIONS FOR EARLY VOTING AT A
RATE OF ONE SATELLITE VOTING
LOCATION PER TEN THOUSAND
REGISTERED VOTERS.
OPEN FOR A MINIMUM OF EIGHT
HOURS A DAY. FOR SPECIAL
ELECTIONS -- BASED ON THE
AMENDMENTS RATIO WOULD BE ONE
LOCATION PER THIRTY THOUSAND
LETTERS THIS WOULD NOT APPLY TO
THE COUNTLESS -- THE COUNTY'S
OPTING TO CONDUCT ELECTIONS
PURSUANT TO THE VOTERS CHOICE
FACT BECAUSE THAT OF COURSE
THERE ARE YOU PROVIDING -- WHICH
I HAVE A WITNESS TODAY TO TEST
BY SUPPORT FROM COMING COST.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS NICKEL
SIDE ON WITH COMMON CAUSE.
WERE A STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SIX THREE TO PROVIDE EARLY
VOTING OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDING
ON WEEKENDS IN ALL CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN MAKING VOTING IS HERE
WE KNOW THAT THE TIMING OF OUR
ELECTIONS REMAINS BEAR TO FULL
PARTICIPATION IN OUR ELECTIONS.
IN FACT ACCORDING TO TWENTY
FOURTEEN PP I SEE POLL WHEN THE
TOP REASONS CALIFORNIA
REGISTERED VOTERS GIVE FOR NOT
VOTING HIS COAT TIME OR SCHEDULE
CONSTRAINTS.
PUTTING CALIFORNIA'S WILL KNOW
CURSE ON A WEEK DAY WE SHOULDN'T
LET THE TIMING OF OUR ELECTIONS
BE A BARRIER TO VOTING FOR
PEOPLE WORK LONG HOURS WERE A
CHILD CARE LIMITATIONS WERE
OTHER CHALLENGES KEEPING THEM
FROM THE POLLS.
EARLY VOTING AND PARTICULARLY
WEEKEND BOATING PROVIDES GREATER
FLEXIBILITY INSULAR VOTING
SYSTEM CAN MATCH THE NEEDS OF
OUR VOTERS.
AND WE KNOW THAT EARLY VOTING
WORKS THE TWENTY FIFTEEN STUDY
IN THE ELECTION LAW JOURNAL
FOUND THE PROVIDING EARLY VOTING
CITES.
A RATIO IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
IS PROVIDED IN THIS BILL.
LEAD TO SEVERAL PERCENTAGE POINT
INCREASES IN TURNOUT.
EARLY VOTING ALSO MAKES FOR
BETTER VOTING EXPERIENCE.
IN SACRAMENTO WHICH IS VCA
COUNTY 15% OF IN PERSON VOTERS
VOTED EARLY MOST IN THE THREE
DAYS LEADING UP TO THE ELECTION.
WITH COMPLAINTS WE HEARD ACROSS
THE STATE ABOUT LONG LINES POINT
PLACES I SUSPECT THAT THE DEMAND
FOR EARLY VOTING WILL BE EVEN
HIGHER IN THE FUTURE. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WERE PROUD STRONG
SUPPORT.
EIGHTY THREE SIX THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
TOMORROW'S THE ROOM VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY ANGER ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK.
TO SING ONE COME ON UP.
NOT DIG ORDERED OR TWEENER MAYBE
YEAH YES WE ARE DATING SELENA
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- NOT OPPOSE
THE BILL I CERTAINLY GET THE
INTENT ONE I WANT TO TRY TO TRY
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND WORKING WITH HER -- STAFF
RIGHT NOW THE THE BUT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR SPECIFICALLY IS THAT --
WE UNDERSTAND THAT IS A PART OF
VOTERS CHOICE ACT ALSO WANT TO
HAVE SOME CONSIDERATION WITH
REGARDS -- TO CITIES WHO ARE
CONSOLIDATING THEIR ELECTIONS
WITH THE COUNTY -- UNDRESSED
BEFORE FIFTEEN THE WAY SO BILL
COUPLE YEARS AGO -- WE'RE SEEING
MORE MORE ELECTION
CONSOLIDATIONS AND SO THE
COUNTIES ARE THE ONES WHO WOULD
MAKE A WHO ARE ADMINISTERING THE
ELECTIONS HOWEVER -- I
UNDERSTAND SHOOT CITY CLERKS ARE
STILL ELECTED ARE STILL CONSIDER
LOCAL ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND SO
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO FIND SOME
CLARITY AS TO THE APPLICABILITY
OF WOULD THIS BE AN ADDITIONAL
DUTY -- WITH OUR ON CITY CLERKS
TO ESTABLISH SATELLITE LOCATIONS
ALTHOUGH THE COUNTY I IS THE
WANTED MEASURE THE ELECTION AND
SO -- THE AUTHORS OFFICES BEEN
GREAT TO WORK WITH SO FAR BUT
LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
CALPERS OFFICE ME BOARD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BRING
BETTER COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTIONS MULLIN.
A MOTION A SECOND JUST APPLY THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR BRINGING THE
BILL AND PLEASE ADD ME AS A CO
AUTHOR WHEN.
THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THIS ROSTER YEAH I MEAN
I'M A LITTLE BIT TORN ON IT
BECAUSE I KIND OF SEE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND AND I
YOU KNOW.
BODY MORE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. TO VOTE.
BUT YOU KNOW IT ONLY APPLIES THE
TRADITIONAL PRECINCT POLLING --
PLACES AND AND PRINT FOR
INSTANCE I LOOK IT.
THE SPECIAL ELECTION IT JUST
HAPPENED YESTERDAY I DON'T THINK
ANY OF OUR COUNTIES OF NORTH ARE
ARE ALL BILL BY MAIL -- COUNTIES
IN YEAH WE HAD A VERY MUCH
HIGHER TURN OUT THEN THE OTHER
SPECIAL ELECTION -- DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY
DO RIGHT SO I DON'T SEE THAT
THIS IS A REALLY AN IMPEDIMENT
TO PEOPLE TURNING OUT TO VOTE --
YOU KNOW PEOPLE.
AND NOW WE HAVE SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTERED RED REGISTRATION WE
HAVE -- YOU KNOW AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION VOTER REGISTRATION
RIGHT BECAUSE YOUR BILL -- SO
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
WAYS THAT PEOPLE HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE PEOPLE CAN
SIGN ANYBODY CAN SIGN UP TO BE
ABSENTEE VOTE BY MAIL -- SO THIS
DOES PUT A LOT OF COST ON THOSE
TRADITIONAL ON THIS COUNTIES
THAT ARE DOING THE TRADITIONAL
POLLING PLACES TO NOW.
HAVE THAT OPEN FOR THE WHOLE
WEEKEND AND HAVE WORKERS THERE
IT'S AND THEY'RE ALREADY.
MANY OF THESE COUNTIES ARE
PRETTY RURAL AND DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF RESOURCES TO TO BEGIN
WITH SO THAT'S MY ONE OF MY KIND
OF LARGER CONCERNS ON AND OF
COURSE -- THEY COULD REDUCE
COSTS BY SIMPLY SWITCHING TO OF
THE CA COUNTY I MEAN NOT THAT
ONE OF THINGS WE WANT TO DO IS
LINE UP -- NOW THEY ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY THAT FOLKS WHO LIVE
IN A VOTER CHOICE ACT COUNTY
HAVE.
RIGHT SO -- I UNDERSTAND IN
SEVEN THINGS YOU BROUGHT UP I'M
NOT SURE THEY'RE THEY'RE THE
SAME TYPE OF OPPORTUNITY AS THIS
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT -- SAME
DATE CONDITIONAL REGISTRATION I
YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY GO TO THE
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS OFFICE SO
AGAIN ON ELECTION DAY -- I MEAN
THAT THAT IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE YOU WOULD HAVE IT
FOR MY COMMUNITY TAKEN ABOUT
SORT OF TAKING OVER AN HOUR TO
GET THERE YOU WERE STOOD IN LINE
WITH.
FIVE HUNDRED OTHER PEOPLE -- I'M
NOT SURE WHO CAN TAKE THAT KIND
OF TIME OFF ON A TUESDAY. TO
VOTE THERE WERE PLENTY PEOPLE
WHO COULD BUT THEY'RE PROBABLY
NOT WORKING FOLKS AND AND AND
THAT WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE AND SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS WERE REALLY TRYING TO
GET AT IS HOW DO WE TAKE AWAY
ANY BARRIERS TO VOTING.
I UNDERSTAND YES PEOPLE CAN --
ASK FOR AND GET A AN ABSENTEE
BALLOT -- AND WE'VE DONE A LOT
TO HELP.
SOLVE THAT WE YOU KNOW IT'S
GONNA BE POSTAGE PAID THEIR
THERE'S ALL WHAT WERE ADVANCING
A LOT OF WAYS BUT THERE ARE
STILL SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESISTANT TO DOING THAT THEY
WANT TO VOTE IN PERSON AND THEY
THEY WANT THAT OPPORTUNITY OR
THEY DON'T KNOW.
YET HOW TO TO REQUEST AN
ABSENTEE BALLOT SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS ADD NUMBER ONE
EQUITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO
WHEN WE HAVE A GENERAL ELECTION
THE PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO WHO
DON'T YET HAVE THE CA EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE TRYING -- HAVE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS PEOPLE HAVE
MISTER MULLINS DISTRICT -- WHO
DIDN'T WAY FAR OUT THERE ON THIS
RIGHT -- AND THAT WE HAVE SOME
EQUITY STATEWIDE AND I I THINK
EVEN THE RURAL COUNTIES THAT
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS
WHO WOULD APPRECIATE THAT TYPE
OF EXTRA TIME.
AND AND ABILITY TO VOTE IN
PERSON -- ON THE WEEKEND BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
IS IT IS THE GOAL HERE TO TO TRY
TO GET EVERYBODY TO TO GO TO ALL
MAIL BALLOT I ACTUALLY BUT I
SUPPORT IT I THINK WE SHOULD I
THINK -- I'VE BEEN BEEN VOTING --
BERMAN ABSENTEE -- WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS THE OTHER DAY --
SINCE I WAS IN MY EARLY TWENTIES
I THINK IT'S FANTASTIC -- BUT TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT TAKE YOU GET
THE TIME THE BILL TO GO TO THE
BALLOT STUDY READ -- KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE AYE YOU'RE GOING TO VOTE
I'M IS THAT THE GOAL WITH THIS
UP WITH WITH THIS BILL.
NOW I THINK THE GOAL IS THAT THE
FACT I MEAN IT.
IN A WAY WHERE WERE OUT.
I THINK YOU'RE ASKING A
DIFFERENT QUESTION IS MY GOAL.
TO TO INSURE THE MORE CALORIES
GO TO VOTER CHOICE ACT MODEL.
YES THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN ASKING
A RECORD OF VOTE BY MAIL BECAUSE
VOTER CHOICE ACT MODEL THE THING
THAT'S SO WONDERFUL ABOUT IT IS
IT HAS THESE VOTE CENTERS IN THE
ABILITY FOR AN INDIVIDUAL -- WHO
YOU KNOW FROM THAT HAS LANGUAGE
ACCESS PROBLEMS MAYBE THAT HAS
HAS NEVER VOTED BEFORE AN IS
CONFUSED -- MAYBE SOMEBODY WHO
IS DISABLED I CAN GO TO TO A
VOTE CENTER AND IT CAN HELP THEM
CAST THEIR BALLOTS IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE BY MAIL ONLY SO I'M
NOT.
I'M NOT IN OF SUPPORT OF OF MALE
ONLY PROVIDING THAT IS THE ONLY
OPPORTUNITY THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO I
THINK IT'S A BETTER MODEL FOR
FOR COUNTIES TO GO TOWARDS OF
COURSE IT'S CHEAPER -- IT
PROVIDES THE THE FACT THAT A
BALLOT GETS IN EVERY SINGLE
VOTERS HANDED BEFORE THE
ELECTION I THINK THAT THAT'S AT
A POSITIVE YOU KNOW ATTRIBUTE TO
IT THAT WE ACTUALLY ARE.
ARE TAKING AWAY PRETTY MUCH ANY
BARRIER TO VOTING AND I THINK
THAT THE VOTER CHOICE ACT MODEL
HELPS DO THAT -- BUT IN THOSE
COUNTIES WERE RESISTANT TO
CHANGING TOWARD VAN I UNDERSTAND
THAT TOO WE SHOULDN'T PUT
INDIVIDUALS ADS -- BECAUSE THE
INDIVIDUAL COURSE VOTER DOESN'T
HAVE AT AT A REAL STRONG --
VOICE IN THAT OPTION RIGHT IT'S
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS --
THE I GUESS THEY CAN TALK TO THE
COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISOR BUT
THEY'RE NOT REALLY HAVING THEY
THEY COULD STILL BE DENIED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE EARLY AS A
RESULT OF THAT THE FACT THAT
THERE COUNTY DIDN'T GO THAT
OPTION.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE
AWAY THAT DISPARITY.
HIS ROSTER.
REAL QUICKLY IS IT AND I GUESS
THAT'S ONE OF MY THAT'S MY
CONCERN IS LIKE A LOT OF US DO
OUT HAVE THE TRADITIONAL MODEL.
AND ACTION YOU KNOW I MEAN THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY MY EXPERIENCE YOUR
EXPERIENCES SAN DIEGO'S
DIFFERENT BUT WE HAVE REALLY
HIGH TURN OUT RIGHT I MEAN ARE
PEOPLE TURN OUT TO VOTE WE HAVE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST VOTE RATES.
IN THE STATE.
AND IT WORKS FOR US AND THEM.
WE LIKE HAVING THAT POLLING
PLACE LOCATION RIGHT SO IT'S
KIND OF LIKE.
THIS SEEMS TO PUT MORE COST ON
THOSE PEOPLE FOR FOR CHOOSING.
T. TO ADOPT THAT MORE
TRADITIONAL MODEL WE STILL HAVE
THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE YOU
ABSENTEE TO DO VOTE BY MAIL --
BUT WE HAVE THE TRADITIONAL
POLLING PLACES IF WE HAD TO
PROVIDE.
NO THESE THROUGHOUT THAT WEEKEND
IT'S IN A IT'S A PRETTY LARGE
ADDITIONAL COST TO THESE
COUNTIES WHO.
WHO ARGUABLY ARE DOING A LOT
BETTER AT TURNING OUT VOTERS
THAN OTHER PLACES THAT?
MAYBE HAVE A DOT EVEN EVEN
PLACES THAT HAVE ADOPTED VOTER
CHOICE ACT -- WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT [inaudible]
THE I'M I'M.
GOING TO WATCHTHE WAY SAY THIS
TO TRY TO BE AS RESPECTFUL AS
POSSIBLE.
I'M VOTER TURNOUT IS TIED OFTEN
TO SOCIO ECONOMIC CLASS.
RACE OPPORTUNITY AND SO ALTHOUGH
YOUR DISTRICT OUR WATER POOR
PEOPLE TO OF I ITEMS AGAIN
GRAPHICS I I I DO UNDERSTAND YOU
DO HAVE A LOT OF POOR PEOPLE
WOULD BE GREAT TO SEE A AN
OVERLAY OF VOTER TURN OUT AND
AND VOTER TURNOUT AMONG YOUR
POOR.
AND WORKING CLASS FOLKS AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR I I'M GONNA
GUESS THAT THERE'S A DISPARITY
THERE BECAUSE TRADITIONALLY
THERE'S A DISPARITY EVERYWHERE
WITHOUT SO I UNDERSTAND -- THAT
THERE ARE SOME FOLKS DOING VERY
WELL UNDER THE MODEL THAT YOU
HAVE BUT I WOULD GUESS IT THAT I
COULD GO TO YOUR DISTRICT AND
FIND A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING VERY WELL UNDER THAT MODEL.
AND AS FAR AS COST IS CONCERNED
IT IS IT VOTING COST RIGHT
RUNNING A DEMOCRACY COST MONEY
BUT I'D ALSO ARGUE THAT OUR OUR
OUR PRIMARY FUNCTION IS THE
GOVERNMENT IS TO MAKE DEMOCRACY
WORK THAT IS THE THE OVER
ARCHING -- IMPORTANT FEATURE
THAT WE HAVE IS A DEMOCRACY IN
THAT WE HAVE TO INVEST IN ORDER
TO MAKE THAT WORK WE HAVE TO
ENGAGE OUR CITIZENS MARIE AND
ALLOW THEM OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENGAGE.
WE WILL ALL BE BETTER FOR IT I
THINK THAT -- YOU WOULD SEE A A
DIFFERENT -- NOW MODEL IN IN
YOUR IN YOUR DISTRICT IF YOU
PROVIDED THESE TYPES OF
OPPORTUNITIES AND THAT THAT MAY
NOT.
BE WHAT SOME PEOPLE WHAT I I
THINK IT'S ULTIMATELY VERY A
VERY POSITIVE THING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THAT
RESPECTFUL ENOUGH.
ALL RIGHT I'LL BRING YOU SOME
NUMBERS THAT'S AS THE VALUE
DEMOCRACY IS WE RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH EACH OTHER.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK -- AT THE END OF THE DAY
THIS IS ABOUT EQUITY AND WHEN I
THINK ABOUT COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE AND SOME OTHERS WHERE THE
COUNTY AS MAY BE THINKING ABOUT
GOING THIS DIRECTION I IN
PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY BUT
HAVEN'T YET -- THAT WE WE SHOULD
PUSH THEM ALONG TIE IT TO TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS THE
RIGHT IN THEIR COMMUNITY TO VOTE
ON A SATURDAY OR SUNDAY -- WHEN
OFTEN AT OUR MONDAY BEFORE THE
ELECTION WHEN OFTEN THAT HAVE --
THE ABILITY TO DEAL WITH THINGS
LIKE CHILD CARE AS THE HOPEFULLY
ON WHEN THOSE DAYS THEY'RE NOT
WORKING -- FOR THE FULL THIRTEEN
HOURS AND AND ADD THE ABILITY TO
GET SOME MORE THAT'S CONVENIENT
AND CLOSE BY -- I I THINK IT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE THIS CALIFORNIANS IN WHEN
WE REALIZE AS WE PUT THESE
OPTIONAL -- THESE OPTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES INTO LAW LIKE WE
HAVE AN RVCA AYE AYE THAT'S A
GREAT THING BUT IT ALSO MEANS
THAT WE HAVE A DISPARITY OF
OPPORTUNITY DEPENDING ON THE
COUNTY YOU LIVE AND THAT'S WERE
TRYING TO RAISE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THE OTHER WORKING
AMENDMENTS TO THIS PROVIDER BILL
WILL MANY COUNTIES NOT
CONDUCTING RESTORE SEXUAL
ACTIONS ARE ALREADY OFFERING
SOME LEVEL OF EARLY VOTING.
THE WEEKEND BEFORE AN ELECTION
THIS IS AN GUARANTEED AS HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED AND IT VARIES
ACROSS COUNTIES SO WITHIN
MOMENTS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS.
I'M RECOMMENDING SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BERMAN
HI.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO MARK STONE.
MARK STONE I LOW.
LOW I MAYES.
MAYES HI MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER I LEVELS OUT ON A SIX TWO
ONE VOTE REGULATIONS BEFORE I
PRESENT MY BILL -- WHEN WE GO IT
MOVED TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WITH SEVEN ITEMS ON THE CAN SING
CALENDAR DAY I'VE GOT A MOTION
AND A SECOND -- DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
JUST FOR YOUR YOUR JOG YOUR
MEMORY WE HAVE ITEMS FIVE ITEM
SIX ADAM SEVEN ITEM EIGHT OUT OF
NINE NINE ELEVEN AND I'M TWELFTH.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR DURING
THE OFF ALL THESE THINGS.
ITEM SEVEN EIGHT AND NINE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT OR AS PROPOSES TO BE.
AN ITEM SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT R.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
AS THE GERMAN COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
I DON'T SEE ANY EFFORTS TO
REMOVE ANYTHING WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CONSENT.
GALLAGHER I'D MARK STONE MARK
STONE HI LO.
LOW MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER [inaudible]
I THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
WITH ON A SEVEN OH VOTE.
AND NOW MOVES TO MY BILL SB.
FIVE OH FOUR WHICH IS SOMEWHERE.
WHICH IS.
I DON'T KNOW
.
FOR THE ROLE YOU [inaudible]
THE AREA.
THE BILL HI MISTER -- SO I
MEMBER BERMAN WOULD YOU LIKE
PRESENT YOUR BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW REQUIRE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO CONDUCT
PERIODIC RESIDENCY CONFIRMATION
PROGRAMS TO VERIFY THE ADDRESSES
OF REGISTERED VOTERS.
IF THE ELECTIONS OFFICIALS WORSE
IF THE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
RECEIVES INFORMATION FROM THE US
POSTAL SERVICE THAT INDICATES
THAT A VOTERS MOVED THAT VOTERS
REGISTRATION BECOMES AN ACTIVE
IN THE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL SENDS
A NOTIFICATION TO THE VOTERS.
LAST KNOWN ADDRESS.
THE INACTIVE LIST OF VOTERS
SERVICES A SAFEGUARD TO PROTECT
VOTERS FROM BEING
DISENFRANCHISED DUE TO
INACCURATE INFORMATION WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THAT ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS HAVE THE TOOLS THEY
NEED. TO KEEP VOTER REGISTRATION
RECORDS UP TO DATE.
VOTERS REGISTRATION IS AN ACTIVE
REMAINS ELIGIBLE TO VOTE BUT
DOES NOT RECEIVE ELECTIONS
RELATED MATERIALS IN THE MAIL.
IN AN ACTIVE VOTER REGISTRATION
EVENTUALLY MAY BE CANCELLED IF
THE VOTER DOES NOT VOTE OVER THE
COURSE OF APPROXIMATELY A FOUR
YEAR PERIOD.
IN KEEPING WITH THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO DEVELOPING
POLICIES THAT PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF VOTERS.
SB FIVE OH FOUR EXPANDS THE
TOOLS THAT MAY BE USED TO
CONFIRM THE RESIDENTS ADDRESS.
OF REGISTERED VOTERS
SPECIFICALLY EIGHTY FIVE OH FOUR
PROVIDES THAT IF VOTER CONFIRMS
THEIR ADDRESS BY LOGGING INTO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S.
MY VOTER STATUS WEBSITE THAT
CONFIRMATION IS SURE IS THAT THE
VOTERS REGISTRATION REMAINS
ACTIVE OR MAKES THE REGISTRATION
ACTIVE AGAIN IF IT WAS AN ACTIVE.
AB FIVE OH FOUR ALSO ENSURES
THAT VOTERS REGISTRATIONS ARE
NOT MADE AN ACTIVE UNLESS THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL RECEIVES
INFORMATION FROM A GOVERNMENT
ENTITY.
THAT INDICATES THAT THE VOTER
HAS MOVED TO ENSURE CONSISTENT
APPLICATION THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AB FIVE OH FOUR ALSO CLARIFIES.
RESIDENCY CONFIRMATION
PROCEDURES THAT COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS MUST FOLLOW THE FIVE
OH FOUR SPONSORED BY SECRETARY
OF STATE -- EXPEDIA AND IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATION ASSOCIATION OF CLARK'S
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS IN THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA IT HAS.
NO OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
TO TESTIFY ARE TIFFANY MOCK FROM
THE OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF STATE
OUT EXPEDIA AND RYAN RONCO.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CLARK'S AND ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS IN PLASTER COUNTY
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS.
PROCEED.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
I'M DEPUTY SECRETARY STATE
TIFFANY MOCK AND ON BEHALF OF
THE SECRETARY ALEX PADILLA.
WE SUPPORT THIS MEASURE FOR THE
REASONS THAT HAVE BEEN STATED
JUST QUICKLY WE REALLY -- A
SECRETARY SERVES AS THE CHIEF
ELECTIONS OFFICER AND IN THIS
CAPACITY WE MAINTAIN THE
STATEWIDE VOTER REGISTRATION
DATABASE THIS BILL SAYS SEN
ENSURING THE ACCURACY OF THIS BY
ALLOWING.
VOTERS TO CONFIRM THEIR
RESIDENCY ON THE AGENCY'S
WEBSITE.
AS WELL AS ENSURING CLEAR.
INSTRUCTIONS AND GUIDANCE IN THE
LAW FOR HOW REGISTRARS CAN BEST
MAINTAIN THEIR LESS.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS.
WE SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND
DRIVE OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MORNING --
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON RIGHT ROCCO PLASTIC
AND A COURT ORDER REGISTER
VOTERS AND THE LEGISLATION
COMMITTEE CO CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PARKS
AND WATCHES OFFICIALS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK CHAIRMAN --
FOR HISWORK ON THIS BILL AB
FIVE BEFORE WILL CLARIFY
RESIDENCY CONFIRMATION
PROCEDURES COUNTIES MUST FOLLOW
WILL CONFORM STATE VOTER LISTS
MAINTENANCE LAW TO A RECENT US
SUPREME COURT DECISION.
ALLOW VOTERS TO CONFIRM THEIR
RESIDENT INFORMATION THROUGH THE
MY VOTER STATUS PAGE ON THE
SECTOR STATES INTERNET WEBSITE
VOEPEL.
AS THE OFFICIALS WHO MUST WORK
WITH THIS DATA WE APPRECIATE.
ALL YOUR EFFORTS PROVIDES CLEAR
DIRECTION AND HOW AND WHEN YOU
EXPECT US TO REMOVE VOTERS FROM
THE VOTER ROLLS ALLY VOTERS MORE
OPTIONS TO UPDATE THEIR ACTIVE
STATUS AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF BIRD IT ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
I THANK YOU WITNESSES IT ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUYING GRAHAM IS FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
AND ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE I WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MOOD BY -- SO MEMBER STONE
SECONDED BY MISTER MULLIN --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE OKAY --
WITH THAT WE WILL.
NOT INCLUDE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN HI BERMAN I
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER HI MARK
STONE.
MARK STONE AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MAYES.
MAYES I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE.
THE BILL IS -- SEVEN IS A SEVEN
TO ZERO RIGHT [inaudible]
RESULTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SO WITH THAT -- WE'RE THROUGH
THE AGENDA LET'S OPEN UP ANY
ITEMS FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND I'M SECRETARY PLEASE GO TO
THE LIST I'M ADDING ON AB TWO
SIX FIVE BY CHOI THE MOTIONS TO
PASS A REFER TO COMMITTEE ON OUR
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I'D LOW [inaudible]
NO NO.
ON A V. TEN THIRTY SIX BY
ACQUIRE CURRY THE MOTION TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
A MISTER LOW.
HELLO HI.
AND WITH THAT -- THE HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY MUCH